welcome to this video playing Grand
Master wrote King yo ok this is a really
strong jamieson super high blitz rating
3500 sin stuff he's a he's a long time
icc player I'm sure unsure unsure who
that is ok fire going to take yeah
that's an interesting line I'm going to
play it in a very simple manner with
Bishop f6 and 83 simply because i don't
know that the sharp theoretical
continuations with bishop age form i
never never learned it ok black here
play so lakiya can play without c6 but
he didn't do that alternatively black
can go home with Bishop f5 and sacrifice
the sea pawn for a moment but as
mentioned he'd hit him here he ignored
the possibility of course this is
completely fine what he did is them
completely normal position it's the very
typical card spot structure normally
coming from the Queens gambit declined
exchange variation I'm trying to play
here on the queenside with b4 b5 the
very well known minority attack
okay this is not very common to be
honest it's this idea when white can
take i mean this is this is kind of kind
of unusual I wonder wonder what to make
out of it I want to refer to think out
of it I didn't know a five looks wrong
so I'm going to take it I thought that
here I actually should be in decent
shape maybe I'm wrong maybe i'm wrong
but it's a complicated position queen
here i'm attacking b5 and this is
serious i will take the pawn if he's not
trading and if he is trading he has this
structure without a 6 plate and this
looks kind of wrong with rook e1 a1
coming he might get some town to play
with the night move and something like
drug see to roots III but I don't see it
really I don't see it happening this
looks looks strange
okay he traded queens could have pretty
moved that okay so I am he was able to
push me back here then I should have
seen really maybe not sure that I could
have done something about it but I
should have should have registered this
move should have registered in my mind
okay i'm going to try 93 to c5 if he
goes Bishop f5 I have bishop after three
ok it's not doing that 93 is a good move
phone interesting that I didn't expect I
get to before now with the nitrous this
is really nice for me attacking d5 and
b5 I don't really see how a defense now
what am i overlooking or am I just
winning a bone yeah I'm just winning a
pond okay so Bishop c6 to win yet
another pawn or provoke the nitrate so
that we play night we play night against
bishop this is this is a nice nice piece
configuration here for the structure
because his not his bishop is tired in
some way to them d5 pawn i'm going to i
could have taken with the f porn that I
was stupid okay can play g4 yeah i was
thinking i can maybe get him outside
passer but that was it's really not the
case okay so i cannot go there
and how am I going to do that um King
before right here or to this dream yeah
put the night on c5 want to enter with
with the King night before as a reason
check it's useful in that regard maybe
he can try to probably not enter with
the king so what I was trying to say let
me think about it for a moment check 1b5
King c6 King f5f three that's winning
check I guess
so King there I will take i will just
take those pawns
now that was far too complicated I could
have could have made my life much easier
am I even winning what am I doing here
am i screwing this up ah Jesus
it was far too complicated oh my god
yeah my twin due to due to their my twin
I'm even miscounting him came I was
stupid then not winning this is really
really bad check unbelievable DRA
offered drawn a lockdown well this is
really really bad not winning this is
kind of kind of difficult I wanted to
play f3 here initially but I mean what I
did should win what about how did I
screw this up so this is this is
actually drawing now I have to play
g-form g4 here cakes and and kini fry
that that's in fact that's really easy
ah he had something I have one minute
fifty this is just dead this is just
dead stupid yeah i played this far too
quickly and TM already i have it already
screwed up amazing yeah yeah it's a draw
and also i thought that actually f3
should when you're right takes chat
leagues takes King c5 this is this is
even even easier
sometimes yeah it was a very
straightforward game I really am
outplayed him completely and then I made
this idiotic places in yachting end game
yeah if five is just just leading
leading to disaster here he's losing the
pawn and maybe you can argue maybe I
played it wrong from a technical point
of view that night against bishop this
is a good structure am now ok
second-guessing is this is really wrong
because I just have to win this this
bloody king and porn again which is kind
of easy but really it's really a yeah I
don't know what's the same let's just
just plain bad to screw this out yeah
that this this kind of this kind of
position is certainly unsatisfactory for
black it should be about equal be fine
that's an interesting way to play it I'm
really not sure here and I don't know
this feels good for me maybe you should
play a six and prevent prevent Queen a
six I don't think that lack should be an
in bad shape or anything maybe this is
the way to do it after Queen a six it's
slightly slightly problematic because he
doesn't get in the a6 move and yeah
maybe Queen B 6 is better than training
with here here I'm definitely better
this is really no question 86 and now
I'm regrouping the night yeah and now it
gets difficult yeah if he does not play
a 5 I mean I'm have you simple ways to
improve nitrous e5 Bishop f3 this is a
complete torture this position so f5
yeah and now we
we get this and I should just win this
but it didn't ah ok what a bad end game
thanks for watching